I don't have a formal speech prepared
but I have a lot of things to say about
Billy Wilder because he's one of my
heroes and I wanted more than anything
to interview him but I was on the wrong
Coast I was living in New York at the
time that I first harbored these
feelings and then one day I got an
assignment from a magazine and they
arranged a telephone interview thing
that was my first contact with them and
the the first surprise that I had was he
wanted a list of the questions in
advance which I've never done before I
like just sort of you know being
spontaneous and and I thought this is
one of the sharpest wits of all time is
he intimidated by having the answer you
know and extemporaneously but I I
labored over 10 or 10 or 11 questions
that I would ask and I sent them in and
he apparently found them acceptable and
then once we were talking we could roll
I found very easily he was happy to roam
around I think it was maybe just a test
or a rite of passage of some sort see if
I knew my stuff or if I was gonna ask
him dumb questions and we had a lovely
chat then when my wife and I moved to LA
we went to oh I was working for
Entertainment Tonight and the show
apparently prior to my arrival there had
approached him for interviews on
numerous occasions and he always said no
not just to us but to any television why
he was again gun-shy I cannot say but he
was so a short time after learning this
we went to a evening at the Academy of
Motion Picture Academy celebrating the
great filmmaker Fred Zinnemann
who like while there was an Austrian
emigres they had worked together very
early on on a film in in Berlin called
people on Sunday which had a lot of the
future filmmakers have note associated
with it so I I went over to him to
introduce myself and he said this is
Freddy's night you know I said I know
I'm very happy to have him and to meet
him here but I also had to pay my
respects to you
I'm such an admirer he said well that's
very nice he says what do you do
I said well you should pardon the
expression I work in television and he
said no no so what was you're working
and of course there was a kind of you
know that that was kind of a irony in
that comment because at that time he was
not in demand
toward the end of his life he still had
ideas concepts even possibly finished
screenplays but was having trouble
getting backing getting financing to
make the films he still wanted to make
so he meant it as a joke but as sort of
kidding on the square kind of joke
anyhow I had another casual encounter or
so with him but it was just so exciting
to be in his presence at all one night
the American Film Institute called me
and said would I be available a week
from Monday
to host a screening for their associates
which is kind of their support group
they were going to be screening some
like it hot with Billy Wilder Jack
Lemmon and Tony Curtis and they asked me
to moderate I said I think I'm free and
I do have a picture of me with the three
gentlemen and we all had a dinner at
long table beforehand you know for a
movie buff this is just this is it this
is Valhalla to have experiences like
that and he was he was such an
interesting man on the one hand he was
known for being a cynic I think he came
by his cynicism honestly
he was born in Austria moved to Berlin
in the late 1920s when Berlin was a very
hedonistic place to be he got to work on
his first movie there as I say mention
on some tag people on Sunday with all
these future filmmakers Kurt and Robert
see adamak Robert see I've not got the
direct and credit on the film the
cinematographer was a future cameraman
of noting ujin's shaft on his assistant
was Fred Zinnemann later directed High
Noon you know other classic films so
what a incredible conglomeration of
talent and Edgar G Ulmer also worked on
the film another layer Hollywood
director
and then of course the Nazis came to
power he fled but his family did not his
brother did w li Wilder who ladies
b-movies mostly but he lost his mother
his stepfather and his grandmother in
the Holocaust
hard to imagine hard to put yourself in
someone's place was experienced that I
was reading up on him and I didn't know
that from his first marriage which was
in Europe he had two children one of
them on a son who died in infancy these
you know these are life-altering
experiences they might make a cynic out
of anybody of course he found ways to
channel that cynicism most of them
through humor which is a great shield
you might say or Armour against some of
the slings and arrows one suffers in
life and my friend Tony slider sitting
here Tony edited as he may have already
told you the diaries of Wilders longtime
screenwriting and producing partner
Charles Brackett
this is a revelatory book a wonderful
very immediate look at a snapshot day by
day snapshot of what life was like
working at a studio preparing scripts
having battles with various producers or
studio executives but it turns out that
Brackett Wilder used to fight amongst
themselves as well they were hardly a
harmonious couple they were sometimes
called that but that was for the public
pose they had their own squabbles along
the way
and but sometimes out of that kind of
tension comes great art or great results
in any case while there was under
contract during the studio system during
the height of the Hollywood studio
system and when he saw that preston
sturges the brilliant screenwriter took
it upon himself to direct one of his own
screenplays in it wasn't an easy task to
convince the paramount chief to let him
do that
supposedly Sturges sold them the
screenplay for a dollar in return for
getting the right to direct the great
McGinty in 1940 he was the first one to
do that while there was the second while
there followed in his footsteps and he
later said as Sturges did that he was
tired of seeing his screenplays Loused
up by a director who didn't make the
most of the opportunities there and both
he and sturgeons had films directed by
Mitchell Eisen who was a very talented
I've been an art director some people
felt he never really built went beyond
the boundaries of being an art director
and never became a very nuanced director
Isle we could argue that point we won't
for tonight's purposes but he wrote
really good movies he and Brackett wrote
really good movies and then he got to
work with his hero Ernst Lubitsch one of
the greatest directors who ever lived
yet another emigres who came to
Hollywood in the 20s during the silent
film and while there just idolized
Levitch and then got to work with him on
not very good film called Bluebeard's
8th wife and then a quite great film
called ninotchka with Greta Garbo
and that to him was that was the
pinnacle getting to work with the great
man himself and when I was doing that
interview with him on the phone I
complimented him on his movie from the
50s love in the afternoon with Audrey
Hepburn and Gary Cooper I said you
really caught the Lubitsch feeling he
said well you can be like Lubitsch
aspire to being but there was only one
loop so he sort of refused the
compliment he would not could not really
compare himself to them to the master he
felt I as an outsider can do it for him
though I think he did capture that that
spirit that feeling what's interesting
and looking at the the expanse of his
filmography is how first off he always
worked with collaborators always and not
just the the famous ones
Charles Brackett who was his teammate
for number of years up to Sunset
Boulevard and then later
ial diamond who wrote the apartment and
almost every film there there actually
they worked on every film I think from
the late 50s to this his death but they
brought in other people as well and
almost everything he did was an
adaptation of some existing work a
silent movie an old play a short story
the apartment is one of their very few
originals happens to be a great one but
I found that interesting he he seems to
have sought out raw material that he had
been mold and shape and in much the way
that in recent years Quentin Tarantino
this is the only time you'll hear that
name mentioned in Billy Wilder perhaps
in the same breath but
but I hope I'm not being irrelevant
because Tarantino takes a lot of hits
for copying or imitating films and
filmmakers that he loves
he has encyclopedic knowledge of movies
and television - and I feel like saying
that people well you try copying the
films you love see how well yours turn
out you know very glib to say oh it's
just a-- it's just a bash up of other
people's movies well maybe it is but
it's then funneled through someone
else's sensitivity and someone else's
abilities and for while there it was the
same the first film he directed from his
own screenplay Brackett was the major in
the minor very cute film with Ginger
Rogers and Ray Milland but it was based
on a on a play an earlier play in short
story when he got done with her that had
the Wilder touch justice Lubitsch at his
touch his second film five graves to
Cairo a very underrated film with Erich
von Stroheim French octone and Baxter
very good World War two movie set in
northern Africa was a remake of a silent
film a paramount silent picture very
different from the silent film because
it was while they're shaped it to his
own liking and so it was over the years
when he received the AFI Life
Achievement Award in the mid-80s
part of the deal of getting this honor
whether you agreed to go to the AFI and
do a question-and-answer session with
the filmmaking students used to call
them fellows
because it was a conservatory and he
talked very freely with them about
anything they wanted to ask and then one
young woman said I don't understand you
say you made two or three films a year
how did you make your deals when did you
make your deals he said we didn't make
deals we were under contract they paid
us 52 weeks a year he went from one film
to the next and that was a concept that
was foreign to that young lady because
it's foreign to everybody now there's no
such system in operation but imagine
having that freedom having that ability
I mean there were a lot of negatives to
the studio system and people have
complained people complained then people
complain in retrospect but the benefit
it had was you had a home you had a kind
of cocoon it was a some people would say
it was a a jail with velvet on the iron
bars you know very comfortable prison
nevertheless if you had the gumption and
he did and the determination and he did
you could surmount some of the obstacles
of that studio system in its hierarchy
and make films that were very personal
topical provocative but even went
against the grain when he made the Lost
Weekend he and Charles Brackett made the
Lost Weekend in 1945 no one had ever
which of course was based on a novel by
Minh in Charles Jackson no one had ever
done a serious study of alcoholism the
subject of a Hollywood movie before
drunks were usually comedy props good
for a laugh a stumbling drunk a serious
even harrowing look at alcoholism
unheard of then seemingly uncommitted
but he managed to get that film date
bracket co-writing bracket producing he
directing and co-writing one Ray Milland
an Academy Award they all took home
awards and it became a success as a
result because it was so potent and so
so honest a level of honesty that people
hadn't seen before from a mainstream
Hollywood movie so he did this over and
over again didn't always work
he made one film and I ain't fifty-one
that is now considered a great film but
was a terrible flop at the time and it's
called ace in the hole and somebody may
have seen it Kirk Douglas and Jan
sterling and it was inspired by a
real-life incident about a man trapped
in a mine and it turning into a media
circle we would call a media circus
well that phenomenon is not new wasn't
knew that the real incident with a man
named Floyd Collins took place in 1925
so it wasn't even new then when he made
this film in 1950 television was still
new ish was it existed people had sets
and was still growing but the film about
human nature and about hard-bitten
reporter who thinks only of himself and
his own glory was rejected by the early
audiences who saw it so paramount
without telling Wilder
when they sent it out into wider release
we titled it the big carnival can a kind
of blatant effort to mislead the public
to thinking they were going to get
something they weren't going to get and
every time Hollywood does that right to
this day and they do it all the time
like selling a drama as a comedy the
trailer you all seen that you know you
see reason where they take all the few
humorous moments in the film and get try
to you know steer you into believing
it's a comedy somehow the aroma seeps
through the screen
and people are very seldom fooled so the
big carnival didn't do any business
either that that title didn't help at
all and and it helped lead to his
disaffection with paramount the but we
live in more cynical times now for
better or worse and people now hold that
up as one of his best films funny how
time can change your outlook on certain
things and it is a great film I
revisited it pretty recently it's
awfully good that seems as fresh as if
it was made yesterday
while her had his being from Vienna
Austria he had a small seaside - and
occasionally rose to the for once with a
spectacular lack of success when he made
a musical with Bing Crosby called
Emperor walls
possibly his worst Hollywood movie which
he has that's his opinion - Bing Crosby
was a big big star while there was a big
now proven success as a director but
things just didn't gel on that movie
occasionally he would call on those
those elements again not not too often
tried to make a light romantic comedy
out of Sabrina with wonderful Audrey
Hepburn and I think a badly miscast
Humphrey Bogart and a barely tolerable
William Holden was an actor I love I
just think they're all wrong for the
roles but the film you know with that
star power couldn't really fail at the
box-office but again it's it's Wilder I
think following his his instincts to a
certain degree to do something a little
small see a little romantic little
uncynical with mixed results but then he
did love in the afternoon which hit
everything just right just right the
right balance of ingredients and that
balance is when it works is glorious he
took a lot of criticism for
using suicide as a plot element in the
apartment some people took great offense
at this saying how can you have a
so-called comedy with you know a woman
so despondent she tries to kill herself
well it's not just a comedy of course
it's it's a social satire it's a drama
it's it's a mixture of things why does
everything have to have a label the
apartment is the unique movie and it
does run the gamut of emotions I think
it's because he had such a firm grasp of
all those elements that worked so well
and of course Jack Lemmon and Shirley
MacLaine were just magic
together on screen with the added bonus
of Fred MacMurray now again following
instincts Fred MacMurray who always
almost always played clean-cut wholesome
light comedy
leaves like dramatic leaves occasional
westerns the Year the year 1944 when
while there cast him in Double Indemnity
McMurray had never played a heel before
never and that he's perfect he's perfect
in that film that data nas between him
and Stanwyck it's great dialogue not
everybody could deliver it the way he
and Stan would do and then 16 years
later he cast him again as a heel in the
apartment but this was a year after
McMurray made the shaggy-dog for Walt
Disney
and the year he started appearing on
television every week in my three sons
so again it was a gamble was a gamble he
took but it was a calculated gamble
because he knew McMurray had it in him
to give that performance and he did his
biggest misstep in the year's foot that
followed there were several was making a
film called kiss me stupid in 1964 and
it's star Dean Martin and ray Walston
and Kim Novak and this film wasn't just
a flop it wasn't just a failure
it was reviled I mean people not only
people just people in the industry hated
it
movie goers what most of didn't go but
those who went didn't like it it was
called vulgar imagine we're in 19 we're
in the year 2018 consider what we think
of as vulgar today and this film seems
you know childish in comparison but it
involved adultery and involved again a
level of cynicism that people were not
ready to embrace and Wilder became
something of a pariah because of this
movie in Hollywood gave an interview to
the New York Times some months later and
said that he felt he had to get busy and
make another movie the people liked so
he'd get back on the godfathers and
pallbearers lists
[Laughter]
and ultimately he did he made a film
called the fortune cookie that he in il
diamond wrote that made a star out of
Walter Matthau and earned him an Academy
Awards Best Supporting Actor which is a
which is also ludicrous because he's the
star of the movie he's supporting no one
he and Jack Lemmon are in the movie
together I think I have never measured
that I dare say he has more footage with
screen time than Lemmon in this
particular Nova's lemon plays a guy who
was hospitalized after an accident early
in the film but Matthau is just
perfection that was Wilder who saw that
and and matha was not a newcomer he'd
been making films since the early 50s
but again while they saw something there
so he had very good instincts and very
good ideas but he wasn't foolproof he
wasn't involved he made mistakes he made
missteps and the problem was as the 60s
wore on and into the 70s that the studio
system collapsed entirely he was
fortunate to have loyal backing of the
nourished brothers company called the
nurse company which produced most of his
films and they stuck with him a long
long time through thick and thin and
there there were several flops during
that that tenure not the least being
kissed me stupid
and then I I sense there was a kind of
almost a desperation on his part to
regain what he had lost so he and
diamond decided to do a remake of the
front page with lemon and Mathis lemon
and Matthau had now become sort of a
de-facto comedy team they were they were
both superb actors who didn't need to
you know rest on that reputation but
they were never going to say no to Billy
Wilder if he want to redo the Hecht and
MacArthur played the front page yet
again they would go along for the ride
and it's a competent film but it's not
inspired film and for once I think in
this case he took material that didn't
need improving that was great just the
way it was and and in fact if anything
he weakened it by trying to modernize
some of the some of the dialogue you
know they kept it as a period piece then
he made a film that was from the heart
the Jack Lemmon called Avanti if you've
never seen this one with Jack Lemmon and
Juliet mills it's it's very obscure it's
available it's on DVD I think it's
available for streaming it's a romantic
comedy drama set in Italy and I think I
think it's wonderful I seem to be
somewhat alone not completely alone
other people like this movie said the
one I'm alone on is his last movie
buddy-buddy which yet again team Ville
eminent man a film which I saw when it
came out in 1985 I said why aren't
people ripping this to shreds it's it's
a funny movie I am alone I'm the only
one that seems to like that I have not I
have not had the guts I will confess to
see it again because I don't want to
prove myself wrong and I and usually I
trust my first impression I don't often
go back you know to see if I I feel the
same way someday I'm gonna have to give
that a try put-put festival litmus test
but it was a failure and that was his
last failed he couldn't afford another
I've always felt how bad could things be
that you wouldn't give Billy Wilder an
opportunity to try something else
but he lived a good many years inactive
now he was still active he still it he
had an office space he and diamond had
an office in Beverly Hills when they
showed up together I think every day and
tried to do some work of course he was
besieged with requests for interviews
and granted some
but he he wanted so badly to be active
again as a filming and here all these
young people would come along get their
shot as they should every every
generation comes along and has to renew
the the system bring their new ideas to
the table that's as it should be what
does that mean we sweep the old veterans
out with the trash I I you know I would
like to think not but Hollywood is noted
for its ageism that's why I was so
pleased to see James ivory 89 year old
James ivory get an Academy Award this
year like okay there's still hope I I
wish Wilder had gotten more
opportunities in his later years the one
thing he did do is he allowed one young
filmmaker but he took a shine to Cameron
Crowe to do a lengthy series of interest
interviews with him which became a book
called conversations with Wilder if
you're interested in him it's a book you
you want to look at now again everything
is from the old man's perspective so he
contradicts some things that he had said
in earlier years some stories come out a
little differently this is this is life
this is human nature and this is the way
things go so you can't not everything is
set in cement but it's very revealing
and I think pretty candid he was also
part of the resettlement operation and
was in Germany when the camps were
liberated in 1945 he saw some of that
can you imagine I can't
but as I say humor was his his armor and
he managed to tell his truths through
humor and express his point of view
through humor and that is a great gift
and that perhaps is it was the greatest
gift of all a gift that keeps on giving
as we revisit his films which I hope to
do the rest of my life and it's so
wonderful that you here at Hillsdale do
these these symposia where you actually
screen the film's not on the TV set and
and have an audience a live audience
because that is the way they were meant
to be seen not alone or on an iPhone
even alone in your room with it with a
decent size television set they were
meant for an audience they were meant to
be seen a little larger than life
sometimes a lot larger than life
and that's how they were designed so to
see them in any lesser form is to lessen
their impact now we all get lazy and we
all get used to our ways I watch films
on TV too
you know and I download and I watch DVDs
I mean it's too convenient not to but if
you ever have an opportunity you should
seize it because that's how you're going
to really appreciate the film to its
fullest how many of you saw the
apartment today good I'm so glad you
took that opportunity because again they
don't happen often enough those chances
and I want to open things up to to you
to ask what you want to talk about and
do we have a second microphone for the
audience they're working on that okay
well in the meantime what we'll do is
we'll I'll just repeat anything you want
to ask so that everyone knows what
question I'm answering if I can answer
it for you don't all rush forward at
once on the aisle there sir now we'll
all be able to hear you clearly just
hang on one second you're talking about
how much you like one two three which
shows you have two excellent
tastehh well I certainly think so I
certainly think so
it was a James Cagney's last major role
he might appear in ragtime time it was a
small part but he was just a dynamo in
that movie and I'm so glad that Billy
Wilder made the movies this so that
James Cagney is giving a little little
older but he's just still ah man that
rat-tat-tat spewing out that dialog with
such a vigor and it's it's hilarious
it's a hilarious movie a wonderful it's
a farce and a wonderland again a topical
fire set in what was then West Germany
when Berlin was divided when the Germany
was divided in Berlin was divided and
one of the things I like best about it
is Andre Previn score because he uses
armed Khachaturian's Sabre dance as the
main recurring theme through the movie I
got to compliment mr. Previn about that
once he thanked me in return so that was
that was nice
great great choice yes one two three
well we're seeing again see but if you
see it with people who are laughing with
you it gets even funnier don't be shy
folks yes you sir
yeah oh I'm sorry I'm supposed to fight
I'm supposed to follow my directions
here grew up today's directors writers
would you compare that had the same
standard and consistent look at at their
films in a way that Wilder did his films
well the first name that comes to mind
not the only but the first name is
Alexander Payne who just had a film come
out that was considered a failure that
again I was in the minority I like
called downsizing but this is the man
who made Citizen Ruth and election and
about Schmidt and Nebraska and sideways
he is a writer-director sometimes he
writes alone sometimes the longtime
partner Jim Taylor
he is a social satirist and he makes his
own films oh it did The Descendants with
George Clooney another wonderful film he
works slowly carefully and makes his own
films on his own terms and I admire him
endlessly and so he's the only one that
comes right to mind as someone who might
be in the same league as Billy Walker as
a complete filmmaker
so we've seen four of his films now so
far and I'm wondering if you have any
particular unifying elements that you
would say are staples of his directing
his writing
unifying elements well again the wit the
sharpness of dialogue the the
irreverence and sometimes cloaked barely
cloaked a topical point of view whether
it's in a film about American
commercialism coming to West Germany
during the Cold War or West Berlin
recovering from World War two in a
foreign affair or evoking the 1920s and
some like it hot the dark side of the
1920s with gangsterism I you know but
this is also a man who made the
Lindbergh story the spirit of st. Louis
you know and adapted and sanitized
somewhat that Broadway hit the
seven-year itch as a vehicle for Marilyn
Monroe so he you know he was not a
one-note filmmaker he tackled and of
course he did the ultimate film noir
Double Indemnity so III think the only
unifying factor is quality yes sir
when it seemed like when Jean want our
women Wilder went over and became a
director as well as a writer he had much
more control over the look of his films
and I saw that especially in Dublin dem
native but even with the Mira SH group
he then had you know they had more
production control and things like that
I was really surprised in this film it
really threw me off that it was in black
and white
it was beautiful where they shot at
widescreen and he had been such a master
of composing his scenes it seemed like I
felt uneasy with it did you really I all
all I think about is that incredible
shot of the insurance office those
endless rows of desks and that's his
great art director Alexander Tron or
another emigres emigrate who worked in
Europe for many years and brought his
touch to to a while there you know he
was he was not a visual list that was
not his strong suit
I think he saw camera work as means to
an end
you know the idea was to tell the story
as clearly and as evocatively as
possible and much like his contemporary
Joseph L mankiewicz who was primarily a
writer who also directed and who you
know would didn't necessarily think in
in terms of visual ideas but ideas
themselves and how best to express them
so I I'm sorry you didn't you didn't he
had a good handle on on the widescreen
again I think of the closing shot of
lemon and MacLean
sitting in the apartment you know
dealing in the cards I think that has
impact and a widescreen frame so I you
know I didn't watch it again today so I
don't have a fresh a view in my head but
I don't recall ever feeling
uncomfortable with it by the way his his
his love of punchlines is something he
shared with macca woods they both loved
having a great finish and they really
were upset this takes some explaining
when long credit rolls started becoming
the norm in Hollywood movies you notice
that at the end of the apartment when
she says shut up and deal and it says
the end you know the MER film released
by nada artists it's over that's what
you take with you as you walk out into
the lobby into your car and to your home
it lingers well nobody's perfect that's
what you take with you and then it then
it with a musical signature dum-dum the
end that's how some like a thought is
that's what you take with you not
assistant pencil sharpener driver
gaffers now again I don't mean any
disrespect to the crews of these movies
I mean no disrespect to them at all but
it was just not how they operated then
and both wilder and Mankowitz felt that
those wonderful finales that they
devised were diluted after those credit
rolls became became de rigueur
thank you so much
enjoying your chocolate do you think he
ever had a sense of self irony regarding
problem of
diminishing career relative
[Applause]
Boulevard
[Applause]
well he made another film that was not
successful called Fedora about a
producer try to coax an actress and
older actors out of retirement and
William Holden played the producer and
and the German actress Martha Keller
played the actress and it was based on a
novella by Tom Tryon and it was not that
good a film and it had a lot of barbs
about current filmmaking in it which
might have been more successful if the
film itself had been a better movie and
I was right around the time I
interviewed him and I asked him if he
saw it as a conical sort of a sequel to
Sunset Boulevard and he brushed that off
and then he said well if you want to
call a Sunset Boulevard - that's okay
yes I think he had a keen self-awareness
and he knew where he stood you know he I
don't think he saw himself as Norma
Desmond because he didn't live in the
past he was not locked into the past he
was aware of current affairs when he won
the AFI what 1.1 when he was given the
AFI Life Achievement Award he was
interviewed red carpet going in and he
said well I guess all I have now to look
forward to is the Heisman Trophy
so yeah he was he was sharp
he was very sharp and he got the whole
picture well I'm with you 1 Avanti
you're alone ok ok
Celebi I want you to talk about a film I
don't think any of us speakers mentioned
this week which is his Sherlock Holmes
the private life of Sherlock Holmes
right which was taken away from him and
what we ever have an opportunity to see
his version er was that lost forever I
think the conclusion is and a number of
people he made a film called the private
life of Sherlock Holmes he shot it in
London with Robert Stevens
and the leading role and a very good
British cast and it was taken out of his
control and at one point I forget who it
was was spearheading an effort to find
them the the some of the footage does
exist apparently in various vaults but
not enough to piece it back together as
he envisioned it and all he said was
this is a film buff joke but he said
don't expect another greed referring to
Erich von Stroheim silent film which was
taken out of his hands and was often
thought of as the the ultimate lost
masterpiece but I don't think apparently
we may see it other fragments but not
not the whole as we would like to
as a hand back there and the other hand
here
[Applause]
yes mr. malt I consider you a national
treasure so thank you so much for being
here
flattery will get you everywhere thank
you very much you mention it I was
wondering you mentioned the interminable
ending you know post
you know the rolls at the end where they
talk about the caterer and the animal
trainer and all that was of course with
Hollywood and usually it's a business
decision why was that done was that
union contract Union rules or do you
know the reason why now we have evolved
and evolved I mean the the other extreme
was not really satisfactory either
because in the early days if you look at
early 30s movie you can fit the entire
crew on one one card or two cards at
most and but then what happened in those
cases is that often just the department
head the head of the costume department
got credit and not the people who really
designed the costumes for that
particular film or the head of the art
department of the head of the sound
department so that was you know that's
not really playing fair either and it's
denying credit to people who really
contributed to the film's now we have
the other extreme there was a midway
point at a certain moment in the late
60s early 70s when the cross started to
happen and then everybody wanted their
piece of the pie I don't think it was a
union thing I think it was just you know
storming the barricades and saying you
know
it's about time we got credit and not
everybody it's still what's funny is
I'll talk to somebody say well I didn't
get great credit for that they left
someone out those credits run for days
who gets left out yes I read online that
Wilder considered the apartment to be
his best film can you explain why well
first I'm sure he took pride in that it
was original piece of work not an
adaptation of an existing piece that he
in diamond you know concocted together
I'm sure that's part of it it it was
very successful it was an Academy Award
winner
so it had popular approval as well as
prestige and critical approval I think
he was just you know a film that
succeeded it on every level and that's
and of course it also transcends genres
with comedy and drama and as I say
social satire thrown in so I would
assume those were the reasons by the way
that the theme the musical theme which
became a hit record at the time by the
piano duo Ferrante and Teicher was not
original to the film and that person
didn't get credit it that seriously it
off Deutsch gets music credits soul
music credit but it was taken from a
British film of the late 40s I'm a
barrister say I can't remember the name
of the film but that was an existing
piece of music that they that they
licensed
thank you thank you very much folks I
really appreciate your attention thank
you very very much
[Applause]